hey everyone welcome to this new video
by simply learn do you know that Google
dominates the global search engine
Market with an
86.86 share digital marketing is rapidly
surpassing traditional marketing
techniques search engine optimization to
marketing campaigns from social media to
content creation digital marketing is
The New Normal marketing it is well said
content is fire and social media is
gasoline the king content can make your
brand Stand Out extraordinarily thus a
lot of digital marketing jobs are
available in the industry in USA a
skilled digital marketer can expect an
annual salary between sixty thousand
dollars to hundred thousand dollars so
if you are looking to become a digital
marketing professional then look no
further then simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing with this
you gain all the necessary skills and
digital marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization search engine
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and more with knowledge
of tools like SC ranking HootSuite chat
GPT Google ads Google Keyword Planner
Google Trends and there's much more on
the list which will help you to attract
the recruiter's eye don't miss out on
this incredible opportunity take action
today and enroll in our course to unlock
the digital marketing success accelerate
your career and gain the skills you need
to thrive in the industry ready to get
started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievements hurry up spots are filling
up fast so without any further Ado let's
know top 10 highest paying digital
marketing jobs for 2023. at number 10 we
have PPC managers pay-per-click managers
optimize websites ranking for organic
research The Leverage PPC to gain
immediate relevant visibility focusing
on ad relevance and quality score for
success to become a PPC manager you need
a bachelor's degree in marketing and a
strong digital marketing knowledge PPC
managers earn approximately twenty
thousand dollars to thirty thousand
dollars annually on number nine we have
SEO specialist SEO Specialists are
responsible for improving company
websites organic search engine ranking
using various techniques specializing in
trending Focus keywords and competitive
strategies to become SEO Specialists a
bachelor's degree in marketing strong
SEO knowledge and skill in diverse
techniques and competitor analysis works
great SEO Specialists earn approximately
thirty thousand dollars to 40 thousand
dollars annually next on number eight we
have e-commerce specialist
the e-commerce specialist oversees
online sales and marketing of products
and services they analyze website and
online store data to uncover consumer
Trends create engaging website content
and set up payment systems for customers
e-commerce Specialists work for
retailers e-commerce service providers
online stores and may choose
self-employment the eligible candidates
should possess a bachelor's degree in
marketing or business management and
practical experience in e-commerce and
marketing
the annual salary of e-commerce
specialist ranges from thirty four
thousand dollars to sixty thousand
dollars annually moving ahead on number
seven we have content strategist content
strategist is responsible for devising
Content plans adapting to market trends
and aligning content with customer
preference the required qualification
includes a bachelor's degree in
marketing journalism or copywriting
along with expertise in SEO practices
and awareness of social media trends the
annual salary of content strategist
typically ranges from forty thousand
dollars to seventy thousand dollars on
number six we have social media marketer
social media marketers promote Brands
and services using various platforms
they create content manage campaigns and
aim to drive website traffic Proficiency
in social media marketing strategies and
audience Centric concentration is
necessary a marketing degree is
beneficial but not always required the
annual salary for social media marketers
ranges from thirty thousand dollars to
fifty thousand dollars per annum moving
to number five we have visual designers
visual designers are responsible for
creating the visual identity of an
organization's brand the other two brand
guidelines ensuring consistent usage
across all channels websites and videos
collaboration with marketing team is
crucial to align designs with the
company's brand strategy a bachelor's
degree in graphic design or in visual
communication is required to become a
visual designer a strong portfolio of
work and prominent presence on social
media platforms are essential the annual
salary of visual designers typically
ranges from forty thousand dollars to
sixty thousand dollars getting ahead to
number four brand marketing expert a
brand marketing expert maintains and
enhances the company's repetition
devises strategies for brand awareness
and identifies new opportunities for
products and services
typically they need to have a bachelor's
degree in marketing strong social media
skills and can work in various
Industries this highest paying digital
marketing job offers around fifty
thousand to sixty thousand dollars per
annum at number three we have marketing
analyst the marketing analyst collects
analytics to Target the Right audience
devices sales strategies and identifies
appealing content for a specific
customer groups they collaborate closely
with marketing team typically a
bachelor's degree in marketing computer
science or management is required to
become a marketing analyst the annual
salary of marketing analyst ranges from
fifty thousand dollars to seventy
thousand dollars
towards the number two on the list email
marketing manager the email marketing
manager is competent in professional
accountable for devising executing and
supervising email marketing campaigns
with the expertise in web Technologies
copywriting and analytics they curate
captivating newsletters expands email
lists and drive sales through effective
customer communication a bachelor's
degree in marketing in any relevant
field will work great for this profile
the average salary of an email marketing
manager is sixty nine thousand dollars
per year
but not the least coming to number one
on the list
which is digital marketing manager
digital marketing manager develops
marketing strategies that align with
business goals and organization they
manage and execute campaigns across
various digital channels including email
social media search engines and display
advertising any bachelor's degree in
marketing or in any relevant field will
work great for this profile the average
salary of a digital marketing manager is
ninety one thousand dollars per year so
if this excites you then do check simply
learns post graduate program in digital
marketing check the complete course
details from the link in the description
box listen to what our Learners say
about our courses in their own words
change is inevitable but growth is
optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learn present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aim for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Purdue University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiling
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High weighting to be rated
as one of the best Education portal
online worldwide is surely promising not
only were the ratings I but also the
courses were economically charged the
modules were very informative and
amazing I still refer to those while in
the final stage of my course I told my
Superior about the certification program
I was doing and then it offered me a
digital marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive yes that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I am pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete eight
Masters program including artificial
intelligent cloud computing and devops
and many more growing requires moving
out of our comfort zones
so here we wrap up the highest paying
digital marketing jobs for 2023. if you
like this video consider subscribing to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates if you have any
questions add your queries in the
comment sections and our experts will be
happy to help
stay tuned with simply learn to make
your digital marketing Journey
exceptional thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here